la violence sexuelle comme arme de
guerre triste réalité dans des zones de
conflit les victimes sont souvent des
femmes et même des enfants c'est déjà
l'horreur mais quand ces actes sont
commis par des casques bleus
censée protéger les populations civiles
c'est encore plus ignoble c'est ce qui
se serait passé en république
centrafricaine où nous en sommes
scandalisés dit le secrétaire général
des nations unies ban ki moon
les agresseurs seront traduits en
justice une enquête a été menée et nous
allons suivre ces recommandations
un scandale qui a miné la réputation des
casques bleus ottawa veut faire sa part
pour la rétablir une des suggestions que
jeu que j'apprécie énormément et qu'on
va considérer c'est que le canada envoie
pas seulement plus de policiers mais
plus de femmes policiers
le canada veut donc se réengager dans
les opérations de maintien de la paix
dit le premier ministre sans pour cela
préciser combien de casques bleus il
enverrait sur le terrain ni à quelle
mission y participeraient ban ki-moon
passerait la journée avec justin trudeau
en bleu plusieurs sujets seront discutés
une rencontre chaleureuse qui fait
contraste avec les relations plutôt
tiède qu'entretenait stephen harper avec
l'onu aujourd'hui le canada veut jouer
un rôle plus important sur la scène
internationale et rétablir son image en
cherchant notamment à obtenir un siège
au conseil de sécurité j'ai indiqué au
secrétaire général que je considère que
d'être de vouloir se réengager aux
nations unies comprend de vouloir
reprendre une place sur le conseil de
sécurité en 2010 l'ancien premier
ministre canadien s'était vu refuser ce
siège au conseil de sécurité
c'est alors qu'il avait commencé à
bouder mêmes a critiqué ouvertement
l'institution nouveau gouvernement
nouvelle approche le canada devra
commencer dès maintenant à préparer son
offensive diplomatique et le canada
joyce veut aussi réaffirmer sa place au
sein de l'otan il le fait d'ailleurs
avec un geste très concret oui céline
l'otan qui va déployer une mission
navale en mer egée pour lutter contre
des réseaux de passeurs et le canada
participera cette mission en envoyant la
frégate de patrouille
fredericton pour lutter justement contre
ces organisations criminelles qui
exploite le désespoir des migrants on a
tous vu ces images trois frégates pour
l'instant participent à cette opération
leur mission sera de fournir des
informations et une surveillance est
essentielle pour lutter contre le trafic
humain
alors attention ces frégates ne vont pas
agir militairement mais elle pourrait
même être appelé à prêter main forte à
des embarcations en difficulté souvent
des embarcations de fortune surchargé
selon l'organisation je vous le rappelle
76 mille migrants sont arrivés en europe
depuis le début de l'année plus de 400
personnes sont mortes noyées
un bien triste bilan
tout à fait merci beaucoup de jeunesse
bonsoir